hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well nikka mccain
athletics book 3 contains a very
important discussion on Aristotle's part
what we can call the liberation and in
that passage he's actually using this
verbal form blemish dye but in other
places he talks about well that assists
the noun what we're going to cover here
is primarily just what is coming out of
this nickel McCann ethics book through
discussion although there are other
things that can allow the account and
add to it in other sections of the work
and other works like for example the
rhetoric so what is deliberation this is
something that's very important to moral
life and decision-making as a matter of
fact it's not only important to moral
decision-making it's important to all
decision making because decision-making
by itself typically does involve some
degree or amount of deliberation he said
that it's an investigation of some sort
it's a Jesus you know the word that that
he uses for seeking you know not every
type of investigation necessarily in
deliberation deliberation is a subclass
of that and what does it engage it's
essentially connected with meanings and
ends it's trying to determine what means
ought to be chosen or judged as the
right ones the in relation to given s
Aristotle says that deliberation doesn't
deliberate about ends it takes the ends
has given to it and then it works from
that basis so you can think about a
person who has already got some some
given aim or intention in sight and now
they're trying to figure out how best to
do it so he talks about two different
aspects of that here what the means are
what are the available means to
something and this might be done through
you know brainstorming right or through
experience that allows the person to
know what the available means are they
can perceive that in this situation and
then it also goes beyond that and it
says if there's more than one mean
available to doing something what are
the advantages and disadvantages of
these various means and ends how can we
weighed them against each other so if he
was for example medicine as you know a
case that he in fact brings up now our
medical technology and our skill our
wing way developed beyond Aristotle's
time his father by the way was was a
physician and Aristotle himself knew
quite a bit about medicine but the
medicine that he had at his disposal was
not what we currently enjoy there's
still a lot of things that are judgment
calls there's still one a deliberation
that has to go into that that's why we
have in fact medical ethicists in
hospitals to help people think through
the these difficult things and when
doctors engage in treatments it's not an
automatic procedure otherwise you could
just use WebMD which some people do to
screw themselves up or to get themselves
a great anxious right now that's said
what else can we say about deliberation
he says that it's about or there's one
other thing before I go into this
Aristotle I didn't put the
baby wants to stress people do in fact
deliberate about everything but none of
those things are what crazy people
deliberate about he says we're only
going to talk about the deliberation
that somebody who is rational would
engage in not just you know the kind of
thing that's like deliberation that
people do engage in you know thinking
should I eat the moon today or should I
instead be made of glass those are
nothing to be really deliberate about
and if you are well you've got bigger
problems than understanding yours okay
so that set what we deliberate about he
says we deliberate about matters that
our action has some role in so there's a
lot of things that go into determining
what happens in life and aerosol names a
lot of some of these things like
necessity right we don't deliberate
about things that are within the scope
of necessity because there's no scope
for our own action to have any impact in
that case there is also a chance things
that are totally up to chance
we can't deliberate about break except
perhaps about what we might do in
response to them but we can't really do
much with that things that are totally
up to other people we don't deliberate
about either things that are you know
not really our business he says you know
the the Spartans don't deliberate about
what the best form of government would
be in some other place now you can say
we do in fact do a lot of armchair
generally or stuff like that on it you
know second-guessing of what people
should be deciding to do Sports is a
great example of this we will actually
tell the vision we say you made a bad
call he should you know should run on
fourth and one right is it C is a
football metaphor we're not really
deliberating in that case because it's
not up to us we're not actually engaged
in that situation I suppose if you're
you know playing your video game and you
know you're you're deliberating about
whether to go on fourth and one and
you're mulling it over then you are
actually deliberating but you're not
a real football game you're deliberating
about something imaginary played out on
the television set or a monitor or
whatever right so we deliberate about
things that our action has some rolling
something that we can actually decide
not necessarily a hundred percent but we
have some stake in it
now we also deliberate only about things
that are possible and this almost goes
along the saying that things that we we
can influence they're our only action
aerosol says you know when we if we
carry out a process of deliberation and
we come to a point where we realize that
there's an impossibility
deliberations over we don't deliberate
anymore because we say I just can't
happen no need to think about what means
would lead to that end that end is not
realizable at this point in time may be
done down the line right you know that
the doctor at a certain point with a
sick patient who is terminally ill is
going to say there's nothing I can do it
anymore
nothing for me to deliberate about you
probably have some things to deliberate
about like your will and want your stuff
to go it sound a little morbid but it
fits into this practical reasoning
doesn't so it's about things that are
possible
we also deliberate Aristotle says about
manners that are not already completely
determined by Sciences or disciplines
you know if you want to deliberate over
whether two plus two equals four unless
you're doing some really weird number
theory that I'm not familiar with you're
probably getting waiting outside of what
Aristotle's calling deliberation right
we deliberated about things that haven't
been completely decided by the sciences
and you know that's interesting when you
look at expert practitioners of a
particular discipline you will often
find that there is still a lot of scope
for deliberation in areas where most of
us would assume it's pretty cut and dry
that's why we actually do oftentimes
need trained
for us who are you know good at engaging
in deliberation about that particular
thing Aristotle thinks that with respect
to the disciplines themselves they have
particular ends that they don't worry
about whether those are good ends or how
they just consider the means of medicine
health right you're not supposed to be
killing your patients unless somehow
that's kind of lead to help maybe by
some utilitarian calculation we're
killing some patients
it'll help someone on a greater number
but everybody else's health itself is
the act that medicine seeks rhetoric you
know if you're engaging in rhetoric its
goal is either persuasion or finding the
means to persuasion depending on what
definition you're going to use the art
of rhetoric and if you're getting into a
reverie classic you're like I don't know
what the persuasion is a good thing or
not
aerosol let's say yeah that's an outside
of the scope of our study you know if
you get into metaphysics class you say
I'm not so big on going with pieas but
again not something we deliberate about
we're gonna gauged in this inquiry we're
engaged in this discipline we're engaged
in this science same thing with you know
ethics aerosol and say you know somebody
might go along and say you know Vice
maybe vice is better than virtue and
Eversole could come up with some answers
but it's the sort of thing we would
actually deliberate about a few things
so um what else it's about things he
says that don't always turn out the same
way so there's a lot of areas in our
life even in things where we have
technical fields where things don't
always turn out the same way where
there's some play where there's some
scope and again this is where
deliberation plays a very important role
in how we do things the last thing that
I want to say is Aristotle says
something really interesting toward the
end of this discussion where he's
connecting deliberation with what he's
also termed deliberative desire or Pro a
racist at his moral choice
Aristotle says that these two things go
together that's why we call Pro a racist
Liberty desire she says it's kind of a
chain of practical activities that take
place first we deliberate about
something we have a given end in mind we
deliberate about the means then we
engage in a act or a process of judging
of literally separating things out
cleaning it's the word that we get
critic from critics judge and so we
first deliberate and then after we
deliberated or perhaps at the end quit
of their process we come to a judgment
once we've got that judgment we then fix
on our desire as he says according to
deliberation which means what we're
doing is we're choosing so a choice
comes after we have deliberated or you
know might say if they're part of a
continuous process where perhaps they
can't pervade each other choice is on
one end deliberation is not another end
and they bleed into each other so
deliberation is going to be extremely
important in moral life because it leads
to choice and choice leads to the
formation of our characters or their
Reformation